if people start sleeping in two
different locations interchangeably at
night that that tends to be a really bad
credit risk so these people tend to use
up a lot of cash in than your future
more than they can afford and the story
they tell me behind that is well those
are people who have lovers and having
lovers leads to divorces and divorces
are costly and costly divorces lead to
loan default so whether that's the right
story behind it or not the boring fact
is that using location data is extremely
useful in predicting your fault Martin
how you doing man good thank you very
much for having me very very happy to
have you on today we've recently been
talking about some big data stuff Seth
Stephens Sevilla it's was on recently
and we were discussing about some of the
interesting analysis that he'd done on
Google searches and pornhub data as well
maybe know pornhub today but definitely
some big data from yourself that's right
yeah lovely
so gives you background what do you do
well my background I grew up in South
West Germany and as everybody does who
is from there I and has any former
self-respect I studied mechanical
engineering but at some point I had the
impression that I can much better
understand what happens in the world if
I study how the financial system works
and that's my made my way to studying
economics and coming to the u.s. and
ended up buying a finance professor and
in the course of that I somehow I
stumble across this topic of AI in big
data and started teaching it the cursor
somehow felt that there was a bit of a
discrepancy between the demands on our
graduates in industry you know which
concerns Python and Big Data skills and
what we taught them which at the time
was largely Excel so I developed the
ambition first to actually make MBA
students teach learn some pipe
in class and apply it and of course the
emission is not attributed data
scientists but to understand what the
economics of data-driven business models
is and can be and how we can understand
the success of tech platforms over the
last decade
so quite involved in the development of
how we analyze the data and pushing that
forward yes so see the there are
specialists on the analysis off data and
you call them data scientists or so and
what I'm trying to spend time thinking
about is predicting future directions of
business models and the development of
workplaces and yeah just how jobs firms
and industries get transformed as a
result of the of the Big Data revolution
okay so this is helping businesses to
make decisions through Big Data that's
right that help that helps business make
strategic decisions on what the AI
revolution means for them how they
should position themselves
it also helps investors in deciding what
kind of businesses they should invest in
or what kind of questions they might ask
businesses they consider investing in
and distinguishing between the you know
thousands of different FinTech startups
or kind of figuring out which ones of
those just have AI in the name which
ones actually apply it and which ones
apply it in a way that doesn't only
solve a technical problem but actually
also has a decent chance of turning a
profit at some point in the future I
understand so is most of the challenge
that you're coming up against here a
technical one with regards to the way
that you can statistically model things
and the the scripts and things that you
can write or is it more so on the side
of how you interpret that data how you
apply it to the market and stuff like
that the letter so the challenge is that
there are very few people that have the
combination of two skills or sets of
knowledge one is understanding what AI
actually is and what machine learning
algorithms do and specifically what they
don't do and the spoiler alert is if you
read the newspaper you don't really get
a good impression of what that is and
there are of course people who
understand that like the engineers that
or data scientists that work with
machine learning models the problem with
that is
very few of them have even basic
economics training or enough of an
economics training to kind of combine
their data science skills with economic
theory in order to predict the future of
industries and markets so that doesn't
seem to be a lot of structure thought
about business models and how they will
change in the age of AI and indeed there
was a book out there which is why we
wrote one yeah so that by the way
business of big data will be linked in
the show notes below of course if you're
interested in today then head to the
link there and you'll be able to find
out even more why do you need someone
whose skill set straddles both areas why
can't you just have the data science
people feed out the data that the guys
who understand economic theory and AI
that why can't you have them just work
in tandem as opposed to to have some on
the bridges well well I suppose you can
have them bring a ton of as long as they
can't communicate to each other but that
is the challenge so if the data
scientists talks to an economist who
doesn't know what a feature is that is a
problem if you explain to an economist
that what the data scientists called
feature you call a variable then all is
good but somebody needs to be there who
translates between these two different
worlds and that's just it's just a
challenge that many firms have so so
what happens if you don't have such a
person see if you read the Financial
Times or whatever the business press you
might get the impression that AI is
about making computers to think and to
replace human beings and that the whole
world is investing it so what do you do
as a top executive trying to allocate
capital for various projects you might
call up the IT department and tell them
hey why don't you you know do AI do big
data yeah at which point the IT
department says well yes and then they
build a data pool and two or three years
later they ask themselves so why exactly
did we do that and how does it fit into
our overall strategy and what's the
product who's the customer what produces
the value in this in this case or is
you know you know the problem your being
that in many cases top management
doesn't really understand what is at the
core of AI in machine learning on the
other hand engineers tend to get very
exciting about solving technical
problems and the technical problems ml
souls is prediction you predict some
stuff but then again there's many things
it could predict and there's a lot of
data you could use for prediction but
ideally that should be informed in a
business that strives to make a profit I
am what economically important and
valuable parts of prediction are and
this is where the communication between
the engineers and the economy so the
strategist has to come in and that
communication suffers from just you know
basically language barriers or or lack
of knowledge on both sides about what
the other side is doing I get it I get
it so what does AI do you've mentioned
some of the things that it doesn't do
what they are used for mostly at the
moment other than preparing for a global
takeover and to make all of our jobs
obsolete well there you go exactly so
that's the kind of thing you read about
right so No Mas talks about the
singularity and stuff and my point is
not so much about whether that's a real
thing and whether it might happen in 30
years the point is that 95% of currently
used mln eya techniques is basically
about a pretty boring technical problem
which is you use a bunch of data to
predict some sort of hard comparable so
what could that be I know everything
about you know your listeners pornhub
watching habits as well as their shoe
sites hair color social network phone
records and I don't know a whole lot of
different variables as well plus the
heart rate variability and at night
between 2:00 and 3:00 a.m. all their
sleeping habits and exercise habits and
I might use all that information to
predict stuff what I could have possibly
predict well I could want to predict
obviously what kind of hands they're
likely to click on so what kind of
products they like what kind of movies
they like to watch but not only that but
also how much are they willing to pay
for it so if I know that you have a
certain travel schedule because I
tracked your cellphone location data in
a precise way I might be able to start
infer how much you're willing to pay it
for airline tickets on a certain
route at particular times and obviously
that information gets valuable if you
manage to exploit it in in a profitable
way so what was the question
what does AI do and what does it not
write so what he does is machine
prediction that is generic in a sense of
you have a bunch of data from the past
and in contexts where the past predicts
the future or the future works according
to similar rules as the past the generic
types of prediction machines can do
faster better and cheaper than human
beings and increasingly so simply
because there's more and more data
around more data than any human could
possibly analyze computation power gets
cheap these algorithms are very
computationally intensive but yeah
that's stuff catchy so data collection
data storage and computation get cheap
and as a result of it machine prediction
got cheap at a given level of quality
that's what it does and it doesn't do
anything else really Computers Computers
don't think like artificial intelligence
has very little to do with intelligence
in a in a broader sense so it is true
that a pretty big part of human
intelligence these days is being used
for generic prediction but that's
exactly what will change watch part 1
what like well there used to be a job
description called loan officers their
job is to know your dad and your your
mother your your friends and your
personal character is evidenced on the
Newcastle soccer team or whatnot and
from all this information kind of
predict how likely you are to repay a
loan and hence whether they should
extend the mortgage to you and at what
interest rate and which which collateral
that is a prediction exercise the thing
is nowadays there are companies that
know much better what your social
network is and whether your dad and
sister and social network repaid loans
and what your current health and mental
health status is and those companies are
called tech companies or data
aggregators and so forth so they are
just becoming much better and cheaper
and faster and predicting no default
what else might you predict you might
predict health outcomes
and you know or the the life expectancy
that's kind of useful when you run a
life insurance company you might as I
said movie watching habits a lot of
things if you drive a car you might
predict whether there's cyclist see
seeing the right of the road is likely
to make a left turn anytime soon and get
in your lane or not all of these are
prediction exercises yeah once you spend
some time thinking about this topic you
see that prediction exercises all are
all over what we do in real life these
things and some of them are generic and
based on a whole bunch of data and a
whole bunch of experience and they're
gonna get replaced and others are not
generic they're not based on a whole lot
of data but are like fundamentally new
here's an example
what about predicting how AI will
disrupt your job or your firm or your
industry the thing is that never really
happened before so a computer cannot
possibly analyze a past data set when
this has happened before they predict
what happens now it has to be a human
being and that's a uniquely human
strength one of the blog posts that I
read last year which was really
illuminating to me was talking about the
role of a top end executive and they
classify the top end executive as a
difficult to replace complex decision
engine that was what they said that the
the absolute top end executives are and
when you look at it from you know I
appreciate the the listeners haven't
read that blog post but it absolutely
blew my mind you got to think the real
value that is added by Tim cooker Apple
or by Elon Musk it's not particularly
his engineering ability it's not
particularly his marketing ability it's
not this that in the other it is their
ability to compile a lot of disparate
complex into woven variables and make
the best decision based on all of those
so that's prediction day all right
that's pretty clear this absolutely
prediction I would however say it's not
generic prediction in particular
they kind of create new collapse no so
what they're trying to predict is what
is demand going to be for a phone that
doesn't have a keypad I don't have to
remember that I'm old enough to remember
how the press was all over how there's
absolutely not gonna be demand and
obviously blackberry was on the wrong
end of this as absolutely not gonna be
demand for a phone but it have to key-in
stuff on a touchpad well how do you
predict that yeah it is a prediction
exercise but it's not that a computer
can do because it's not in it hasn't
happened before in the past so an AI
algorithm machine learning algorithm
cannot analyze the past data set to make
that prediction absolutely yeah that's
the the safety the mechanism I suppose
there is inherent in being an executive
being a top-end executive allows you to
protect your own job by being the only
person on the planet that knows that
very particular set of variables and is
able to extrapolate forward from that
and say this is what I think that we
need to do and I suppose that's where
some people talk about business as an
art form or being an executor as be a
CEO board member as being being a
creative artist in one way or another
and it is that isn't it it's taking all
of these different variables and seeing
something that potentially isn't in the
data so I agree with that now let me add
one level of nuance it's not so much
about a job of top executive or there's
about particular tasks that the
executive might take that is more useful
to think about so we right now talked
about predicting the demand for no
keyboard cell phone well what about
coming up the creative process of even
coming up with the possibility of having
an attached touch phone that so far is a
rather uniquely human kind of activity
that a computer has absolutely no
advantage advantage doing so the kind of
I don't notice intuitive creativity I
guess you were referring to synthesis as
well seeing a bunch of trends in the
world and somehow synthesizing them in
an intuitive way
in order to make these creative
predictions that is something that
humans are uniquely good at so far at
least yeah looking at some of the stuff
that we were talking about before what
why does my bank care how fast I fill in
a form why does he have to know that or
what see what another why does a bank
care how fast I fill it right so see
this is an example right about in the
book
I spend a lot of time talking to friends
in China China is I'd say at least half
a decade ahead in the AI and big data
game is really due to various reasons
and a yeah a friend of mine who is a
head of AI research at a company called
Huawei that you know recently was in the
news once or twice tells me yeah you
know one really important variable these
days is how fast people fill out online
forms I say what wait why and it says
well see first of all if you type your
social security number or your National
Insurance number however it's called in
the country from which you're listening
that kind of tells you a lot about the
person if you can't fill in your social
security number real fast and you're
probably a fraud or I don't know not
particularly intelligent or something I
don't know it tells you something about
people's willingness or ability to repay
a loan or how big of an insurance risk
they are or similarly if you make lots
of typos while filling out a form
perhaps you're not a particularly
careful person but whatever you know the
theory is behind why these variables
predict outcome as well they appear to
work really well in predicting loan
they're thought as well as insurance
risks so companies start collecting it I
never thought until I heard this story
about that anybody might track how fast
I fill out online forms but they do Wow
yeah that is that is super interesting I
was on Skyscanner flight comparison site
only a couple of months ago and the
particular flight that I was looking at
I watched I refreshed the page and in
front of my eyes it went up by 300 300
pounds and I was thinking there's not
there's not this many people looking at
this particular flight to Vegas right
now there's me there's me and there's
the guy sat behind the screen that's
just said I'm gonna I'm gonna screw him
to the tune at 250 quid and then I went
back and I ended up booking the flight
to Vegas just in between Christmas and
New Year and I booked it and it had gone
back down to below the original price
but it changed as I was looking at it
refresh the page changed as I was
looking at the page and I was like
there's a guy at Skyscanner that's just
gonna [ __ ] well a guy or of the Sheep
or if the machines a guy as well yeah
yeah you are right there is he
physically there's a guy with a button
and the button made it happen
mmm-hmm yeah see I have never I asked
myself for years why nobody does that to
me so you're the first time that the
first data point that I hear reporting
such an incident and so I don't want to
extrapolate too much about it but see
it's a it's an it's an interesting point
right so the website can see how
interested you are and how desperate you
seem to go in a particular date and
particular time know so what they're
predicting is really a willingness to
pay for a particular ticket a particular
time now obviously that can be very
useful but I imagine that you may not
have felt super happy about that price
increase and obviously they increased it
so much that you didn't buy the ticket I
might even suspect that you might be
less willing to use that particular site
in the future if you suspect that
they're using your search information
against you yeah so when you think about
this for a business perspective what a
business executive might want to keep in
mind essays
seek to exploit the data where users
generate is ethical considerations if
not because they themselves care about
the ethics but the customers might and
that might be and to get the kind of
intuition of what makes people upset
that's kind of like really valuable now
get really upset at being charged a
different price from another person but
you know what people really love getting
individualized discounts so you got a
discount but your neighbor didn't now
when you think about this for more than
like two or three seconds you're like
but that's the same thing yeah but it's
just very diff
to people no absolutely and and what we
just described all of the above but with
coming up with variables that you never
thought about could possibly potentially
predict your credit risk or the
intuition about what people get upset
about these are completely human
exercises and it is precisely about
predicting the future of IIA and how
they transfer from industries and jobs
and websites and searching for flights
and so forth where humans have a huge
edge over computers because it hasn't
happened before you know so educating
oneself about those particular areas is
actually a great skill to have as the AI
revolution takes a lot am i right in
thinking the Amazon split tests it
prices I've heard some some some reports
about two people going on to the same
product and Amazon doing a whatever it
was that you mentioned desirability to
buy or desire to buy split tests on some
of its prices for things just buy pens
so I don't know that for a fact
what I have noticed myself is that when
I put a certain item in my basket in my
shopping basket but I don't immediately
buy it and I come back a while later to
take a look at it I'm frequently
confronted with the fact that the price
of that item may have changed increased
or decreased now I don't know that this
is because I'm azan is running an
experiment on me what I do know is that
this creates data it does create data
about whether I'm buying a certain item
at a certain price or whether I'm not
and that can be analyzed and used in
order to infer individuals willingness
to pay for certain items now again I
can't tell you how much deliberation is
behind that and Amazon would likely not
tell me if I asked but for sure this is
one area where listeners are becoming
aware right now that they're generating
data that people can go and analyze and
use to estimate you know predictor of
future behavior why why does my car in
sheera care about my email address is
that the same thing as the bank the bank
filling in a bank for yeah I mean
just ask this to the listeners and you
know do you know anybody who has an au a
Oh L address boy my dad did until I
forced him to get rid of it and anymore
he upgraded to I think what he
considered to be modern which was a
yahoo email earth very good suppose that
I was offering an insurance product that
I really don't want to offer to older
people based on this particular example
that it just offered I would assume that
offering that to AOL and Yahoo users
would not be in my best interest because
I would be targeting an older audience
know me so it's not particularly because
AOL per se or Yahoo per se are somehow
bad or tell you that this person is a
bad insurance risk but being an AOL user
correlates with characteristics or
features of people that might very much
matter for the riskiness of the
insurance poor that's a data point
inferred from that data point is a
particular skew within the data that is
indicative of other things and you can
use that too that's right make a
judgement it's starting it's starting to
fit together what else have we got
oh yeah checking your phone in the
morning and where you sleep at night
what about that tell us about that China
where people tell me everything's coming
out of China now I mean what I'm
recording on a logitech at the moment
what's that what's Logitech is Logitech
Chinese I don't know I bet I bet there
it will be someone someone behind the
scenes will own logitech that they'll
have a controlling share from China well
okay so you have to update me here on on
what you're after here just Logitech who
they it I I thought they were Swiss but
I don't know who's actually behind them
so Wow that's it China I'm telling you
ah anyway so China
what time you check your phone and why
you sleep at night tell us about that
well so I said so so what they tell me
is that if people start sleeping in two
different locations interchangeably at
night that that tends to be a really bad
credit risk so these people tend to use
up a lot of cash in than your future
more than they can afford and the story
they tell me behind that is well those
are people who have lovers and having
lovers leads to divorces and divorces
are costly and costly divorces lead to
low default so whether that's the right
story behind it or not the boring fact
is that using location data is extremely
useful in predicting a false let's have
a less juicy story and just say see say
your uber or didi when you want to go to
China and you know where a person lives
because you know you have stored a home
address in your in your app as well as
where you work that gives you a really
good idea about what the guys annual
income is if the person moves to a
richer and more prosperous neighborhood
that tells you something about whether
their salary we end up what kind of
restaurants they eat at which of course
as a right helling company you know
because that's where you drop them off
or pick them up it tells you a lot about
a particular person as well know simply
how fancy the restaurant is so obviously
Canfor a lot of things about the
person's current liquidity situation
from simply analyzing the location data
and nothing else and guess what didi a
year ago or two actually started lending
arm as you would expect from a company
that knows so many things about
individuals that are relevant for
predicting loan default Wow well okay so
you know it's it's fun how I can impress
people the way I do this too in the MBA
classes is to tell them the economic
theory of how clearly a ride hailing
company should be offering a lending
product sometime soon and I did that in
the class and I heard all the respect by
my students because a week later uber
started and I'll take away now the thing
is I didn't actually predict that I just
knew that didi had done it a year
earlier in China
as I said as I said it's not very hard
to predict what happens in this world as
long as you basically follow what's
happened to China over the last five
years why why is China so far ahead with
this well I think there's at least four
reasons let's see we talked about some
of them in the book let me see if I can
still get them together I mean number
one I said at the beginning what machine
learning is really useful for is
analyzing huge data sets otherwise you
can use confidential statistics now
China has a large population in a
recently homogenous economic system so
well just by virtue of that you have a
lot of data but also for each of these
individuals you have lots of different
data points because for various reasons
the Chinese the Chinese people appear to
tend to be less privacy concerned or if
their privacy concerned they just get a
lot more convenience out of the apps
they have so with the kind of apps that
that we chat say offers you can't do a
lot more things than with whatsapp in
the US right so if you think of Mark
Zuckerberg trying to merge Instagram
with with whatsapp and Facebook data
that's what happened in China many many
years ago so their messaging app you can
already transfer money so essentially
you have a useful currency there you can
make your doctor's appointment and you
can buy your life insurance so you can
do for each assets yeah basically it's
all in the same app they call it a super
app okay so now so so I said well why is
it useful to have all these apps within
one app wait think about this I just
said you make the doctor's appointment
in the same app that you buy life
insurance well you know guess what you
can probably predict the remaining life
expectancy of a particular person a lot
better if you know what kind of doctors
appointments they're in the process of
making now so this just illustrates that
using data that you generate in one part
of the business can be really useful in
another part of the business so having
all these diverse sets of businesses
under
Rufe and you might say why doesn't
messaging service you know help with
merging back with Facebook or Instagram
data that's kind of like the answer you
get different types of variables about
the same people and that turns out to be
incredibly useful for predicting well
all kinds of stuff the thing that is
coming to mind now as we talk about this
more and more it's obvious that there's
massive amounts of data that are being
collected it's also obvious that some of
these data correlates are really useful
for companies right that makes them
powerful right one of the problems that
everyone that's listening can well think
of is right okay so let's say my life
insurance provider has direct access to
my doctor bookings from the company's
side I can see why that would be great
for a customers side that could be great
or it could leave me suffering at the
hands of higher insurance premiums that
potentially aren't fair or anything else
and based on the company's ethics based
on something that's completely out of my
control now I'm at the mercy of this
company which knows more about me than I
did I couldn't agree more so so I think
you mentioned that a lot of different
things so one is fairness some people
some alarm bells my drain and you might
people might find things unfair well the
company might say well you're free to
not use your our app but the problem is
it's kind of hard to be a functional use
human being in today's society without
any using some sort of technology I know
some people who try my my my cycling
buddy from grad school is now a computer
science professor at Berkeley teaching
machine learning and in particular
fairness by the way and his wife works
at Google in an AI team and he does not
have a smartphone this is the same as is
it that scares me is it Elon is it Elon
Musk or Tim Cook it doesn't let their
kids have iPads in the house yeah well I
yeah you know it's kind of
this has a similar spirit to it all now
here's the thing about the same because
I don't particularly like the idea of my
privacy being invaded by I don't know
whom but on the other hand I really like
to use Google Maps because otherwise I'm
having a hard time travelling and
getting to places in a reasonable amount
of time you know so basically there's a
trade-off between privacy and
convenience you might call it an
anecdote like 2000 in 2006 or so the
u.s. started taking fingerprints when
you enter their country and it was a
huge outcry in Germany about how this
outrages and how can they and so forth
and people just boycott traveling to the
US and so forth said well that's all
very nice but I just got an offer to go
to grad school in the US I'm actually
not going to go to grad school in the US
because the fingerprinting and obviously
answer is no no now fast forward 12
years later I travel across country
borders I twice a week and use these
automatic you know scan your passport
scan your face kind of portals and it
goes a lot faster than the old passport
control and I'm perfectly happy about it
no so yes they use my personal
information they know all kinds of
things about me all my biometrics I have
no idea where the data goes and we use
it but it's just so much more convenient
and this is basically where things come
down on I think we got into this when we
talked about China when I talk to my
Chinese friends they say well it's not
that we're not concerned about privacy
but it's just so freakin convenient to
use apps so and in this trade-off we
just come down on the side of well yeah
I guess you know people know everything
about me already anyway so what's the
point of me
those enjoy going off the grid like yeah
like like your friend is that the
primary benefit free from the user side
convenience because it seems like other
than convenience you're at the mercy of
the ethics of the company for better
decision making also yes so it's it's
not just the ethics so because again if
there's competition between companies
customers might get upset and switch
companies that actually protect privacy
you know that's how the whole topic of
Big Data interacts with antitrust law an
antitrust enforcement but we can't get
into or not but but I'd say see from the
economic perspective you can say the
company is the first set that machine
learning machine predictions do is just
it lowers the cost of stuff
uber is just cheaper than a taxi company
for various reasons but one of the
reasons is you don't have a human being
that is trying to connect a person that
calls a taxi you know phone hotline with
a driver and who skirted some part of
town you just don't have that human
being in the loop and you make that
process more efficient according to
conventional economics now so that's
that's the first benefit you get just
basically the same product cheaper
better and faster that's a lot of
benefit for the consumer if there's no
abuse of of the information you then
eluded to oh but you could do all kinds
of nasty stuff with the data well yeah
that's a concern that especially looking
into the future customers might be
concerned about being price
discriminated so being charged precisely
how much they're willing to pay because
you know you know you've got an
indication of where they work and why
they live and from that you can deduce a
salary and you say well this person
that's going from a poor area or
whatever we can charge them a little bit
less or the guy that we knows just how
to raise and just bought a brand new
half a million dollar house where we can
charge him more
that's right or you might imagine that a
right hitting company might at some
point sneakily ask you before showing
you a fare for the ride will you accept
this ride no matter what the fare will
be and that actually happened to me no
way and I wasn't a rush and just take
yes but because whatever in the promo
doors and Russians that weighed snap
completely price insensitive they could
have charged me whatever they wanted
yeah so that was probably not a
particularly smart move on my behalf
so I wanna I wanna get into the the
trust side and I guess the litigation
side of this as well because there has
to be well there might not be you might
tell us that there's not I would think
that there has to be some limits to what
companies can do with our data and I'd
love to find out about those but first I
someone asked about China like why why
is China so much further ahead have they
got better engineers is it just the fact
that they've got all of this data to
play with if the US had as much data as
China would they be able to be as a half
a decade ahead right or so so yeah so
let's get back to this topic says that
more people then they have better apps
that are more convenient so people are
willing to spend more time on the apps
and thus generate data they manage to
collect more features then there's
basically no privacy or in the trap and
Trust roadblocks like GDP are there of a
comparable nature just a while the West
in China is it and they they do have a
ton of engineers who work on this stuff
like just one auto or one insurance
company ping'an has more than a thousand
engineers that do nothing else then then
programming I know
and you're you're gonna have to look for
an insurance company in the West that
pushes this agenda anywhere near it as
much you go to the academic conferences
and see not only the number of
submissions but also the fraction of
acceptances you start to see China a
Chinese University is just getting way
ahead at this point in from the West so
it's it's all of the above it's all the
above that makes China have an engine
okay so antitrust what is antitrust
what's that
well antitrust is otherwise otherwise
known as competition law or the
enforcement of computation laws and this
relates to this topic in various ways
one of it is we talked about Facebook
previously and their desire to merge
whatsapp Instagram and Facebook data
which previously they said they would
never do but now currently they change
their mind and the German competition
watchdog the Buddhist continent warning
named Warren believable name
say that again what is it wouldn't
discover loved oh that is amazing so
badass and German isn't it
amid the following argument they say see
and it's not illegal to be a monopolist
what is illegal is to abuse a dominant
position and here's the argument they
made they said see people care about
privacy if there was a social media
network site similar to Facebook that
offers a similar benefit but that is not
Facebook and that actually cares about
people's privacy people would put
actually choose that alternative side
over Facebook but such a site doesn't
exist and Facebook does not honor the
prior Missy preferences of the users
hence is Facebook is abusing the
dominant position so this is obviously
paraphrasing what the argument is
roughly is and they simply prohibited
Facebook from merging these these
diverse data sets as it pertains to
users that are under their use diction
and have absolutely no idea how that is
actually measured I'm German but I don't
live in Germany so I don't particularly
know well I have fall under that or not
very you currently are I have no clue
how that actually works the point it is
just to illustrate that competition in
forces can actually come up with
effective arguments in order to throw
roadblocks into business models that try
to prey on getting information from
these different parts of the business
you know as we just described is
happening in China right and left
Facebook is trying to do it as well but
especially in Europe I suppose
regulators are are throwing roadblocks
into these kind of attempts as part of
that because in Europe you've got this
you could look at Europe as one big
country that's federal essentially and
you'd have to jump through the hoop of
France then the UK then Germany then
Norway as opposed to an America where
you've just got one thing or is this
something systemic about Europe that is
anti data anti big tech it's a good
question CTD P R is a Uruguay thing and
the example I don't know cousin in the
US right
there's no equivalent in the u.s. in the
in the US particular states are starting
to get very sensitive about these issues
as well but it's certainly it's
certainly very different so I think yeah
it's both a federal and a European wide
issue that there seems to be more care
taken with respect to data privacy it's
surprising to some you know Norway for
example if I'm correctly informed having
nest you know those home video camera
kind of things it's kind of illegal here
for privacy reasons you can't have that
which obviously is not the case in the
US and people are surprised about this
because there's anyway is Norway a
country where everything is transparent
you can see your neighbors salary and I
don't know what and the court that the
government collects all kinds of data
about you that's what my American friend
says and I say in response I tend to say
wait have you heard of the NSA it's not
like it's not like your government
doesn't connect the data about you they
just don't make it available exactly
have you heard I don't know what the new
product is from Amazon one of their new
products maybe like one of the echo dots
or something like that and as everyone
was opening it up for Christmas there's
some stories of Amazon engineers being
on the other side of it pretending to be
Santa Claus and doing all sorts of weird
stuff there was a lady who got death
threats from the other side of that yeah
yeah people with other people in Amazon
[ __ ] with everyone oh wow so I didn't
read about these particular ones but I
mean I think what you're illustrating is
just that there's just a real let's call
it business risk if you take the
perspective of the business in how
people react to the innovations that
you're offering them and again there's a
convenience store it off and the privacy
thing and the question is which way you
wrap people more and you know and what
you find Alexa more intrusive or you
find it more useful and I guess that's
the that's kind of like the cutting edge
that companies have to navigate at this
point the bizarre thing is for the
people like myself I guess who I don't
fully understand all of the privacy
concerns but I've watched enough Netflix
documentaries to be scared right but
for me in the back of my mind I'm always
thinking about that trade-off with
something so I don't have a Amazon Alexa
or a Google home pod or any of that sort
of stuff I don't have that I don't have
it particularly because of a privacy
concern but if I was to buy one I would
think about it I feel that right okay
what am I am I prepared to forgo my
privacy for that for me it's not a
massive a massive element of my
decision-making but it would be in there
and what's interesting is that when you
get to see behind the curtain which is
my Skyscanner example right had I have
been anchored at the higher price had I
have logged on and refresh the page and
it had stayed at the lower price or had
logged on the first time and it was at
700 pounds the higher price and then
refresh the page and it stayed the same
I first off I wouldn't have this story
to tell you second I wouldn't have
mistrust in the site so part of the game
that's being played here with regards to
our privacy and the way that data is
being used is the transparency of our
cognizance about it happening not
whether or not it is happening it's
whether or not the user becomes aware of
it and that creates that creates an
environment for the company to
purposefully try and be as obfuscating
around what's being on what's happening
with your data as possible well it's
true or to frame it differently I
previously said that people hate
individualized pricing but they love
individualized discounts you know so
it's a question of how you frame stuff
as well and yeah I mean you know some
companies at the cutting edge of this
are are where you're head of the head
consideration already but you know many
others will follow and have to make
these sooner decisions I would I want to
throw in and like switch switch sites a
bit and make an argument to not scare
people it's pretty easy to scare people
yeah yeah with these privacy concerns
but here's another one so say why do I
have a cellphone I do have a cellphone I
have a smartphone among others because I
find it really useful but even if that
wasn't a dominant consideration do I
really help myself by not generating all
this data so say
say I was concerned that a health
insurer is is using all kinds of data
about myself to price my health
insurance am I actually concerned that
I'm a worse health insurance risk than
the average person in the society I live
in probably not I'm kind of like in
shape and you know do sports and I'm
generally healthy and all that good
stuff
so I might actually want the health
insurance company to know all these
things about me if that makes me get a
cheaper price and I would get without
the phone so true they might still
exploit my willing my extract some of
these rents and but on the other hand I
might still get a much better deal then
I would without generating all this data
for them so it's not entirely clear that
you know living in autarky
actually prevents you from leaving a
trail because if you then apply then you
belong to the - to the set of people who
don't have a smartphone live in the
woods all they're doing is feeding on
whatever they can find around the
outside of the shed yeah no I want to be
counted as those yeah which side of the
fence do you fall on because previously
when it's us versus company there's
always been these tricks of the trade
you know like sort of between maybe the
70s and you hear these stories about
armed
Bill Gates getting free phone calls by
like phone hacking putting in particular
tones back through the receiver to be
able to make free international calls
that was one of the first things he did
right so there's this there was this
period this golden era where companies
were able to offer a services but they
hadn't caught up with all of the
different ways in which people the users
could obfuscate their information right
so you could be a guy who looked
perfectly in shape but know that you've
actually smoked twenty a day for the
last thirty years and then somehow get
around that and get to whatever but if
your health insurance company knows your
bank records and sees that you've bought
a packet of cigarettes every day for the
last thirty years you can't get around
that again but the problem is or the
concern is going to be when do I fall on
the side of the fence
would have been better for them to not
know this information about me well you
won't know they know but that's that's
part of the problem so see um that game
you're describing is definitely being
played and will be played a lot more
there are these these fitbit's or how
you know whichever company you you work
with that counts a number of steps huh
you have fun in SC and I'm not telling
you this all right um if you know that
your insurance premium goes down if you
take more than whatever 10,000 steps a
day at some point it might occur to you
they're just making your dog run around
with it during the day is it much way to
achieve the same outcome would produce
the same data this month this one's
doing 70 thousand steps a days a psychic
but it's amazing and he can run it 43
kilometres an hour well in China you can
actually buy small electrical devices
that do nothing else and shake around
your Fitbit during the day on your desk
you're kidding no of course you can it
has to occur to the data scientists
analyzing the data that the users are
actually trying to generate a certain
you know a certain type of data that
you're incentivizing them to produce so
you might actually have to change your
algorithm and say hey we have to
correlate the heart rate of the guy or
thing that's when you need to attach it
to the dog isn't it we're gonna have to
shave you have to shave a little bit of
the back of the dog's exact back to the
dog's paw so that you can get a good
connection for the optical the heart
rate monitor exactly so all this to
illustrate that this is a dynamic game
and the stuff is being changed and
perhaps is useful a useful place to talk
about what computers can do in this game
versus humans this conservation we just
said is a completely human interaction a
computer would never come up with that
that perhaps something has gone wrong
with you know how people use the the
Fitbit or the app it's important this
poor person who's been having a seizure
for the last 10 hours yeah exactly
or what this person can have a heart
rate of 247 yeah you know a computer
would know what to do with that in the
end it's a human being who sends behind
that which tells you that it's not that
computers are intelligently analyzing
datasets computers compute stuff that's
what they do but the intelligence has to
sit behind the screen and have a you
know human brain attached to it and come
on in creative ways has theories about
what generates the data said what causes
the data to be generated the way it does
and therefore which changes in the
company who policy or incentives that
you offer to your user will actually
have what kind of effect on their
behavior and that's a completely
theoretical exercise right you're saying
hey if I change prices if I change these
step incentives in a certain way how
will that cause people to misbehave or
you offer penalties for abusing it or I
don't know what you do this is stuff
that has never happened in the past so
computer cannot analyze a data set and
predict what how people would behave in
response to that it's a completely human
prediction exercise and this is where
the opportunities lie in that field to
think about what compliments economists
say what compliments cheap machine
prediction and the answer is like
intelligent humans that understand what
the computers do and creatively think
about you know the ethics economic
theory think about whether you only see
a correlation in the day an hour when
it's causal that have some sort of moral
compass or understand how users think
about the ethics of what you try to
connect in terms of the data collection
I don't know with humor have you ever
seen a computer come up with a joke I
follow the follow a guy on Twitter who
keeps on posting these images that he
says are machine learning scripts for
stand-up now I think that there him
writing them as if a machine did them
because they're so side-splitting ly
funny and it's like it involves the it
includes the audience interaction and
stuff like that absolutely
be insane I don't know I haven't seen a
computer be funny not yet
yeah right so people people actually
trying to do this right and and tons
computers are starting to be good of
kind of puns and you can see why because
you're just analyzing a whole bunch of
language and puns that people find funny
and you know then it can predict what
kind of a combination of birds people
find funny okay fine so far so good and
you know they're successful whatever 52%
of the time so that that isn't I don't
know that's probably a better rate than
me in the classroom but fermented me
it's funnier than me by miles but you
know it is it's doubtlessly true that
computers by now can can come up with
funny puns so if you have a human being
that selects all those that are funny
and then gives them to an audience great
that worked but it's still a human
judgment that's behind the that's behind
the exercise don't you so one of the
things that you've mentioned so far is
computers struggle to predict in
situations that there's no essentially
no precedent for yes will that change
well people are trying but let's let's
say this is the main point we're trying
to make in the book is that's 95 percent
of what you read about in the newspaper
like thinking computers essentially but
it's very a very small percentage of
what actually happens in the real world
what happens in the real world is that
people assemble humongous data sets
about your behavior and predict which
movie you want to watch next okay so
that's the stuff that actually happens
that's economically viable so as people
think about what actually affects their
real life in the next five or ten years
it's definitely not thinking computers
it most definitely is a bunch of fancy
statistics that is really boring to talk
about it's a bunch of Engineers yeah
analyzing big data sets and that's it
and has nothing to do with with thinking
computers and all these are you know
more exciting and hence more headline
generating things that you that you
really about elsewhere
I suppose you know thinking about Nick
Bostrom or max
egg mark that there kind of either
utopia or dystopia depending on how you
look at it for the fugitive AI when you
look at what they talk about they're not
talking about essentially the world's
best statistical model er what they're
talking about is artificial general
intelligence right they're talking about
a thinking a thinking computer but yes
it would seem at the moment you know
there's that there's that um at a
particular conference a few years ago
someone asked a room of experts how long
do they think it would be before we
reached artificial general intelligence
I don't write it was the singularity but
it was certainly official general
intelligence and like the the consensus
was like 50 years like before death
right before 2100 right and by the way
that was a consensus in the 1950s to the
same oh the same distance from the night
so it's 50 years from 1950s and now 50
and it's just moving as we goes on okay
so whatever the right number here is the
point here is people have talked about
this for decades and decades yeah and
the horizon has shifted out see you can
call me wrong if it happens next year
and and I ridiculed the idea but as you
say the closer people are actually to
the forefront of research the further
out into the future it seems to be that
they expect artificial general
intelligence to be there yes so our
point is exactly hey this is a very
exciting to talk about and people have
and it's a very appealing thought to
human beings apparently but what
actually matters in the real world right
now and what affects people's lives is
boring statistics hmm and that the my
point here is we've got this is when
it's gonna happen artificial general
intelligence you know this is what's
super intelligence which is one of my
favorite books and everyone who's
listening who really really wants to
kind of get a good grasp of how
artificial general intelligence might
come about should read super
intelligence by nick bostrom it's
awesome this is kind of the terminator
romantic view that is been put in the
press but that's not what's being
economically rewarded right now what's
being economically rewarded right now a
big datasets being analyzed cleverly so
that you can make good predictions so
you have to presume that as we move
forward the resources are going to be
disproportionately moved
that direction they're gonna be
discriminated towards what can make
Amazon make more money or what can make
my insurance company make more money not
should we throw a trillion dollars into
maybe making artificial general
intelligence when we don't know if it's
possible that's exactly right so this is
exactly the point see see if you want to
see what currently makes money for
businesses look at the market cap of
companies and you'll find companies such
as Amazon Google and Facebook up there
don't you or of course the Chinese text
tech giant's so what do they do well so
one thing I showed my MBA students is an
annual report of Amazon in 2006 and so
that's you know like 14 years ago or 13
and what you see is Jeff Bezos talking
about that they have the ability the
data and the technical ability to
analyze what the column is essentially
called price elasticities for demand so
if you change the price of a certain
good how are people going to react to it
are they gonna pay more or less of it
and how much more and how much less the
techniques by which they analyze that
that's basically just dead boring PhD
level or actually more like tenure u.s.
top university professor level
statistics and economic trig modeling
and this is exactly the people that
Amazon hired over the last few years is
literally like hundreds of PhD
economists that analyze these data sets
so if you want to use what produces a
trillion dollar market cap you just have
to see what they do and it's just you
know econometric or economic modeling a
whole bunch of data science on huge data
sets has absolutely nothing to do with
artificial general intelligence and
that's what yeah that's what's recording
rewarding companies right now right
that's right get em get em to choose
well and and the financial markets
expect that to reward companies in the
foreseeable future right because that's
what market caps of companies are it is
expected to take expectations of future
profits talking about it on a wider
scale then we haven't touched much on
the global economics of this but what's
your predictions moving forward is this
going to change anything are we going to
see market caps and and those
predictions moving more or less
so you know is it gonna change the way
that the actual financial markets
themselves are going to be manipulated
or going to be judged by by the
companies that looking after them yes
please please go on so I'm a finance
professor so there's a risk of me
tapping into it into finance topics a
little too much for for this audience in
financial markets the most successful
hedge funds and market participants are
precisely those that have used computer
science and models for the last few
decades predicting future stock returns
and it works like a charm and and people
are rich okay fine
so in financial markets there's a huge
transformation happening and I'll get
too much into that you know asking much
broader a much broader question so I got
invited a lot to investor conferences um
that I like I read about AIA in the
newspapers a lot and there are thousands
of startups but first of all is this
just a fad and second if it's not just a
fad then which of these sorts of
startups am I supposed to invest in how
do I think about this and and what I
tell them is well see why is there so
much AI it's because there's a lot of
data
hence big data why is it so much data
well because it's cheap to collect data
it's cheap to store data and it's become
cheap to analyze it okay and when the
product is cheap people buy a lot of it
and it conv says demand curves are
downward sloping but okay you can forget
about this again if you don't care when
things are cheap people buy a lot of it
it's really cheap to collect data I can
get your cell phone location data if I
the data aggregator a few hundred bucks
and they will tell me where you are it's
very simple it used to be impossibly
expensive and I need to hire a private
detective no longer okay some guy in a
leather suit and okay so that's why
that's the earth now this is just a fad
well unless you tell me a story why data
collection and data analysis is suddenly
going to become way more expensive again
the answer is no it's not just a fad
it's gonna stay here now let me
put a small disclaimer in there which is
I can actually tell you a story why it
becomes more expensive to collect and
and process data and it's called legal
constraints think gdpr
in Europe so sure if politicians wake up
or to these concerns are convinced by
these concerns they might throw
roadblocks in it and it's gonna differ
from your restriction to your
restriction and therefore here in this
business that's one really important
consideration you should have in mind as
you get into this field well which leads
to the second question which kind of
businesses should invest in given that
you want to invest in the space in
general or which one companies really
want to work forward so flaws I mean one
is one question is concerns to the legal
jurisdiction but the other one is
understanding what the economics of
their business model is is it a business
model to make better predictions than
the competitors and therefore like
offering a better product okay that
sounds great is their business model to
have some sort of useful thing people
like and that people are willing to give
up their personal information for but
the example I would think of is like
scooters
you know inner-city scooters or bike
sharing and stuff the question of these
business models has very little to do
with the weather the fee people pay to
rent a bike actually pays for buying the
bikes and I don't know keeping them
charged and maintained the economics of
it is that you sell the people's cell
phone location data to a data aggregator
who sells it to Facebook or Google or
whoever wants to buy it which they use
to target ads okay so let me let me go
backwards in this value chain obviously
correctly targeting ads is a valuable
thing from a business perspective but
you need a bunch of data for it where
does the data come from well in some
cases the companies like Google and
Facebook collect the data themselves but
in other cases for other variables like
how fast you type your name in an online
form they might buy it from a data
aggregator the data aggregator buys it
from whoever first came up with the idea
of measuring how people have has people
buy stuff in an online form and whether
that's an online form for car insurance
or an online form for I want to rent a
scooter in Madrid doesn't matter the
first bit no and this is why I'm saying
hey the logic the economic logic of
business models really changes as data
itself becomes valuable because the
whole point of your business model might
be to collect a bunch of data and it has
absolutely nothing to do with the
product if you program a flashlight app
for a phone but somewhere in the terms
of conditions you say that you also want
their entire address book and their
their the the the location data how
faster they type the names and check all
their activity on the Internet
I mean if you get people to sign up for
that well good for you you don't know
any yeah you don't need it for the
flashlight app not so I'm sounding very
cynical and I suppose I am
this is not an endorsement of these kind
of practical practices or me saying this
is ethical all of a saying is like this
is what is happening out there in the
real world indeed there are ethical
constraints to it indeed legal
constraints are there and start popping
up but that's the economic logic of how
business models are changing presumably
as well because this is such a fledgling
market that's moving so quickly the
there's an asymmetry in terms of how
many people want data to be more
available from the company side how
sophisticated they want the modeling to
be able to be and the decisions that can
be made off the back of that versus me
and you thinking I I don't want my data
to be sold to these people I should
speak to my local councillor who's busy
like dealing with like a you know a
proper like a flood or like a real a
real sweat real-world problem that's
gonna make news as opposed to mean you
saying I think if this keeps going over
the next 20 years this could be like
Orwell's 1984 and but you know that like
so where does the rubber meet the road
with regards to protection for users
well I think it's a societal decision
see and I mean in the end of the
political game alluded to previously in
Europe both individuals and politicians
seem to be more in a car Society
concerning data collection and in some
ways interests in a vague sense and as I
said previously I don't know maybe
that's a bad thing
I mean first order having more data
enables better decisions so as long as
it doesn't get abused in some sort of
way
having companies that I don't know give
me I love over having taxis in in the
small town in the u.s. we're live for a
long time was a disaster
I loved over coming along and offering
me cheaper it's normal so so first order
this is all great the question is just
when the concerns come in and that
depends a lot on how many companies
start abusing the power they they they
have thanks to the information and how
politicians react to it either to the
company's concerns or lobbying efforts
yeah the lobbying the lobbying must be
so that must be where I would imagine
companies like Amazon and Facebook are
really ratcheting up their spend you
know if first off they needed to get a
lot of computer scientists up next they
need to get the lawyers and the
lobbyists who can protect the work that
the computer scientists are doing yeah
and the economists I suppose so see oh
what do you get from all of this is the
sense that there's gonna be a few
winners in this space and there's gonna
be a bunch of losers now and obviously
that's a societal concern everybody
talks about inequality and this is one
mechanism by which you know which can
drive it and as I said I don't expect
this to stop anytime soon
it's gonna go faster than some of your
restrictions and in others it goes
fastest in China for the reasons we
discussed so if you want to see you
whether you want to live in a society
you know that has very little regulation
around is these topics you can look
there and see if you like it there's
many things I like about it go to
Germany and try to pay it with a credit
card in a supermarket it's gonna be hard
because they like cash meanwhile in
China you walk past the supermarket
counter they scan your face and that was
it oh my god is that beautifully
convenient you know it's similar like
the airport the airport face scanning
technologies whatever it's it's not a
technical problem that has been unsolved
I mean how much would you like to not
have to stand in line at a supermarket
because some person in front of you is
trying to you know count individual
coins to get the precise amount you're
like in the 80 on my face I've put my
stuff in my face there you know it's
just incredibly convenient so I I do not
want to be per to mistake about which
kind of society
want to live in it has huge benefits to
live in this more technologically
advanced world my prediction is that
likely we're going to move in that
direction more than not but to which
extent and how fast and in which your
restriction and who makes the money that
those are the exciting questions from
yeah an individual perspective an
investor's perspective a potential
employees perspective and so forth and
we can watch China we can just see what
happens in China they're like the the
canary in the coal mine or the monkey
that got shot out into space and it's
like if they're if their entire society
breaks down and it becomes a dystopian
waste world where Mad Max is like just
chill out a little bit for a while right
so I mean the sea I hope this end said
that listeners will get from this is
that is definitely not a time to just
sit back and just because you can still
pay with cash in your supermarket as
fine you think that kind of like immune
from this that's all hard works you're
just five or ten years behind and this
is not ideally where you want to be in
this space because as I said it's moving
incredibly fast Wow
Martin today's been today it's been
awesome where should people head don't
get the big the business of big data
Amazon Amazon that's that's what they
should that's that's where to find it
that's the only place to find it in fact
and I can't wait to hear people's
reactions it's it's our first book on
this topic
the first attempted and we'd love to
hear back yeah I've got to give a shout
out to Yuri as well so the guy you're
your Co co-author on the book right so
we got to know each other when I was a
grad student at Princeton he was an
undergrad and he wrote a popular book on
statistics and I always thought there
was an oxymoron but he somehow managed
to pull that off so it tells you
something about that that he's really
really good and a funny writer and I
very much enjoyed enjoyed him there and
working together with him on the book
and I hope it shows he's he's also been
in touch with him ever since I got
introduced to the browser by David
Parral last year I've been in touch in
just back and forth just nerdy stuff
that'll send him something that I've
seen this thing do have a look at this
thing and he'll always always take time
to reply to me
so yeah if you haven't the to the
listeners if you want to sign up to a
service which allows you to get curated
articles every day and then a synopsis
of them at the end of the week this has
been the only reason I actually think
that I'm interesting over the last
twelve months that the only reason I
have anything interesting to talk about
is because of the browser's daily emails
where they send me like random articles
about like how high a pig can jump or
you know yeah it's that's exactly what
it is but yeah that'll be linked in the
show notes below URI thanks so much for
the link-up man
my in business of big data will be
linked in the show notes below as well
ladies and gentlemen it's been awesome
going go and put some sellotape over
your webcam and and make sure that amaz
aren't watching you do not use stuff in
your bedroom thank you very much
[Music]